one of the most iconic faces in the news
this week was Swedish teenager and
climate change activists Greta tunberg
yeah he's awesome yeah she's like a hero
to my daughter kids everywhere young
people and and old alike just a hero
well this is sad but conservatives have
been doing everything they can to
undermine her the president even mocked
her on Twitter now conservatives have
gone even further they found a teenager
who's a passionate climate change denier
and they're parading her around her name
is grinko Austin lark
she's 15 and she'll be appearing on Fox
and Friends tomorrow but tonight she's
making an exclusive appearance here
please welcome Greg de Austin lark
[Music]
hello everyone okay drinka I I want to
make sure I'm getting this right you do
not believe in climate change no I am
tired of being misunderstood I do
believe in climate change but like your
McDonald's hamburgers with a pop-up door
I'm loving it
you're loving climate change alright I
feel like you're ignoring a lot of scary
climate change science no you are
ignoring me I was home-schooled by my
mother who teach me that science is a
concept invented by liberal media just
like sleepovers and friendship there's
no such thing
shame on science okay I'm honestly
shocked that you believe this and I am
shocked too never did I dream that I
would see Exxon Mobil's annual revenue
drop below 280 billion dollars it is
disgraceful and I will not stand for it
well clearly Sweden produces some
outspoken young people apparently how
dare you
I am from Austin Texas you're from
Houston yes I sound like this because
the chemicals in my drinking water made
my tongue swell it's good yeah sure it's
great yeah I just think kids like you
should be dreaming about a better
cleaner planet that's all thousand
Shane's upon your head Conan you do not
control my dreams like my dream of
owning oceanfront property in Las Vegas
on my dream of frolicking around inside
a beached whale carcass on my dream of
consuming all the raw beef and cool I
desire
[Laughter]
that's good cool it softens your teeth
okay
[Applause]
yes now I'm hungry for cold I know